so we've seen this leak to report what
the government is supposed to approve
what's your first reaction to what we've
seen so far yeah I mean I think it's
very positive you know the industry has
really been excited about this this is
something we've been building towards
since 2012 and what we saw leaked is
pretty similar to what was kind of
proposed over a year ago when the FA
first put out some of these rules for
comment so it's actually pretty similar
to what we were expecting as far as the
operational environment for the operator
is what they're going to actually
require the operators to actually be
certified by so it's I would say it's
pretty well in line with what the
industry's been inspect do their rules
go far enough I think so I mean for this
type of operation where you're flying a
small you know drone within you know a
somewhat contained environment this is
something that ensures that it's safe
ensuring operators are safe that they
understand the rules of the road and
there's actually ways to find out you
know exactly where they're flying who's
flying what aircraft so there's a
there's a trail that goes back to
understand if there is an issue who
exactly was responsible do you think the
restrictions should be looser I mean are
there are other changes you would like
to see changes around like flying at
night for example yeah I mean there's a
lot of really critical applications for
example beyond line-of-sight is one of
the ones that is really critical for
companies like say an energy company or
electric utility to fly long range over
their power lines to really understand
what's happening it doesn't make a lot
of financial sense to stop every mile or
two to go and catch up to the aircraft
launch it again so beyond line-of-sight
flying at night those types of things
are critical for this to really show our
oh I know you guys have been doing most
of your testing abroad right in Africa
we've been actually doing a lot of our
work here in the United States for
several years so we've been working
commercially here in the United States
right now you can fly under what's
called a section 333 exemption which
lets you do similar types of operations
that are in these types of rules we also
work with a lot of the FA designated
test sites and that actually lets us do
things like flying in neighborhoods and
those types of things for the insurance
use case looking at rooftops those types
of things so we were actually able to do
quite a bit in United so how will these
new rules change your business at all
well I mean it's it's going to allow for
error particular we're still going to be
able to do a lot of the work we're doing
it's going to make it easier for our
customers for example to go out and
operate on their own
if the barriers to entry for say a large
corporation that may have been waiting
for some of these rules to come out now
they can go ahead and start operating
it's clear what the rules are it's clear
what they're going to have to do to get
up and fly so a couple weekends ago I
was out with my family at a beach park
and there is a drone hovering above us
have no idea who's operating it you know
it was fine it moved off and it came
down just fine but as as just a consumer
as a person just out there in the
environment should I be worried about
this no I mean my kids are sitting under
this drone and I don't know who's
controlling it and I don't know if they
really actually have control yeah i mean
this is this is the safe technology
right i mean this has been used by model
and hobby community for decades it's
been used by the commercial industry now
it's been reused across a variety of
different industries so you're saying
that nothing could go wrong with that
drum what if you know the power shut off
or some person got knocked over with
that drone just safely land without
hitting anyone or and it depends on the
type of drones for example a lot of the
commercial systems have things
engineered directly into them to account
for a variety of different things that
could go wrong but even in the chance
that something like it happens the fa
now requires registration so there'll be
a registration number on that aircraft
and if they're not in compliant with
that then they can be subjected to any
other sort of enforcement action what
about accidents in the commercial sense
I mean there's there's a lot of things
that can come up in the case of R&D but
in the in the commercial industry these
are people's livelihood in business at
stake and this is critical for them to
ensure that when we're going to put
something out in front of a customer
that it's something that's safe
something that can be flown over and
over again safely especially when it
comes to the insurance industry oil and
gas utilities it's it's absolutely
paramount that things are safe